as we've heard greater manchester and
lancashire are getting
extra government support because of a
surge in covid cases
so what's going on well the weekly
infection rates for
berry manchester and particularly
blackburn with darwin have been soaring
over the last
month but look what's been happening in
bolton the original hot spot of the
delta variant
cases there are coming down as a result
of surge testing
and the extra support now being rolled
out elsewhere
so who's getting infected well these are
heat maps the darker the color
the higher the infection rate and in
bolton where the virus has been
spreading for longest is reached
all age groups but elsewhere it's far
more common
in young people age 16 to 29 town
after town the same pattern and look
it's been heating up
most in the last week well let's focus
on bolton then for much of this year the
infection rate of
older and younger people has broadly
been in sync until the beginning
of may when cases in the under 60s who
are less likely to be protected the two
doses of the vaccine
just took off as the delta variant took
hold
only coming down as surge testing began
to work
and it's the same story in blackburn
there again
it is the in the young where cases have
surged whereas
in all the people they've remained
relatively flat and the vaccine is also
preventing serious infections
weekly admissions to hospital have more
than doubled in the last two weeks
across
greater manchester but they're not
rising as fast
as in previous waves despite the current
surge in cases
patients are younger and they're less
sick which will be a relief
for the nhs